EFETOBORE TASKER: I would
say that the key to success
for Junior Lab for
me was simply having
the perseverance to continue
to work and to get things done.
Because as I said, I hadn't
done a class like this before
or I haven't done anything
experimental in physics before.
So a lot of this was new to me.
And I found it very
difficult at first.
But if you put in the time to
learn how to correctly take
data, to correctly
analyze data figure out
how to do error
propagation, things
like that, you'll
eventually figure out
a way to do it in a
way that's correct.
Because they do give you that
background and that foundation
to teach you how to present
data, how to analyze data.
But we just have to
take the time to learn.
So I think that perseverance
was the key to success for me.
SAARIK KALIA: Yeah, I
think one thing I actually
found pretty surprising
about the course
is I kind of expected
the hard parts to really
be like the measurements,
as opposed to the analysis.
But I actually found it to
be the other way around.
Like, obviously you have
to be attentive during lab
and know what you're doing.
But oftentimes the
real difficulty
comes outside of
class, like doing
proper analysis of your data and
really knowing what's going on.
And even a lot of the
times you should really
be doing analysis during
class so that you know
if your data is good,
if your data is bad,
and adjust accordingly.